العربيه تواصل نقله عمليات اجلاء رعايه من
جنسيه مختلفه الذين قدموا من السودان
والان بعضهم يغادر وكذلك البعض الاخر قد
غادر في وقت سابق هنا نتحدث عن رعايه من
الجنسيه الباكستانيه اكثر من 140 شخص من
الجنسيه الباكستانيه الان يغادرون
علامات طائره من نوع ايرباص
من نوع ارباص
319 وهي من تابعه للقوات المسلحه
الباكستانيه طبعا هذه طائره خاصه
هبطت مغرب اليوم او بتوقيت المحلي في تمام
الساعه السادسه من مسائل هذا اليوم بتوقيت
محلي السعودي وهي في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه في مدينه جده والان تقوم
رعاياها الى باكستان طبعا ما زالت وما
زالوا
الركاب وايضا من تم اجلائهم من السودان من
رعايه باكستان وهم يقومون الان
من النزول من الحافلات الخاصه بالقائده
والتوجه الى الطائره سوف نقوم ايضا باخذ
جوله سريعه داخل هذه الطائره وهي كما ذكرت
من نوع ايرباص
319 تابعه للمسلحه
الباكستانيه هبطت اليوم في تمام الساعه
السادسه مساء بتوقيت المحلي السعودي وسوف
تقوم بحمل اكثر من 140 شخصا من من رعايه
باكستان طبعا عدد هنا الان بدا في الدخول
الى داخل
الطائره وبدا
الرايه الجنسيات المختلفه يقومون باخذ
مقاعدهم هذه هي صور خاصه للعربيه ننقلها
ومشاهد اوليه لرعايه باكستان الذين وصلوا
وقاموا بالدخول الى
الطائره واخذوا اماكنهم المحدده لهم طبعا
العدد كبير هنا طبعا هذه الرحله او هذه
الطائره هي تعتبر الطائره الرابعه او
الخامسه التي تقوم باكستان باجلاء رعاياها
وايضا تقوم كما قامت ايضا طائرات اخرى من
جنس او من دول عديده مثل الهند وكذلك
تايلاند اليوم قامت باجلاء رعاياها عبر
طائره خاصه تابعه للمسلحه التايلانديه
الان هذه طائره باكستانيه وتعتبر طائره
الباكستانيه هي الطائره
بالنسبه لباكستان التي تقوم بنقل رعاياها
من قائده الملك عبد الله في جده الى
باكستان
هذه القاعده طبعا نصفيان ابدا
نعم لم تهدا وكذلك لم تؤثر الحركه
الموجوده فيها على الخدمات او ايضا
الملاحه الجويه بشكل عام او على مسار
الخطوط التجاريه بشكل عام وكذلك ايضا لم
تهدا او لم يهدا حركه السفن او لم تهدا
حركه السفن في ميناء جده الاسلامي او كذلك
في مياه البحر الاحمر او تاثرت على حركه
نشاط السفن التجاريه التي تقوم بنقل
بضائعها من السعوديه الى الخارج او كذلك
في عمليه الواردات او
تاتي الى السعوديه او ايضا تخرج من
السعوديه ولكن هذه العمليات التي تتم هي
لعمليات انسانيه تنفذها دول عده
باتجاه مدينه جده وايضا تقوم دول عده
بالاستعانه بالخارجيه السعوديه لانهاء
معاناه رعاياها الذين كانوا في السودان
هذه هي الدفعه الان الاخيره من هذه الدفعه
الاخيره نعم من رعايه باكستان الذين الان
تم استكم ودخل جميعهم الى داخل الطائره
بحضور القنصل العام الباكستاني وكذلك
قادمن من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه وهم
ايضا يقومون بتوديع هؤلاء رعايه باكستان
من
بعد توجه وايضا دخولهم الى داخل الطائره
طبعا المطار هنا او المطار قائده الملك
عبد الله هو كبير جدا خلال الاسبوع الحالي
قامت اكثر من 21 طائره بمغادره من هذا
المكان اضافه سواء طائرات اجنبيه او كذلك
طائرات عسكريه تابعه للقوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه التي قامت ايضا باجراء
رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه وقامت ايضا بنقلهم
من السودان الى مدينه جده وتحديدا باتجاه
هذه القاعده او هبطت هذه الطائرات
العسكريه التابعه للقوات الجويه الملكيه
السعوديه على ارض هذه القاعده وستستمر
العمليات عمليات الاجلاء حتى نهايه اجلاء
اخر رجل ام انه في فتره محدده هاني صفيان
لهذه العمليات اعتقد ان العمليات الاجلاء
تهدا ولن تتوقف ما زالت العمليات جاريه
بينما نحن نتحدث الان عن هذه الطائره
وكذلك بوقوف عدد من الضباط وضباط الصف الى
داخل داخل الطائره عفوا في توديع هؤلاء
الرايه هناك ايضا طائره سعوديه في
الخلفيات تستعد ايضا في الاقلاع ولعلنا
ايضا
نرصدها في النشرات القادمه طبعا العمليه
الاجلاء الى بورتسودان هي مستمره سواء عبر
الجسر الجوي او كذلك عبر الجسر البحري
والذي تنفذه سفن عديده وهي منقسمه الى
قسمين اما سفن تابع للقوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه او كذلك سفن عسكريه وسفن
تجاريه اجنبيه وتنفذ ايضا على ثلاث مواقع
قائده الملك عبد الله بدويه هنا الجسر
الجوي وهناك ايضا من الجده الاسلامي
وقاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات